how about how about we uh do you guys
want to
waste time talking no let's let's
yeah personally
madonna or we can talk about something
what's madonna up to yeah oh gosh all
right let's talk about talking about
madonna
hot minute i think this is one of those
stories that we can get in trouble for
talking about
it's uh
man this is this is more of a pop
culture kind of thing but i also think
i kind of want to talk about it she got
a lot of face work done oh yeah but yeah
a little bit so take a look at this
madonna's bizarre tic toc video raises
eyebrows as fans grow concerned over the
star's unsettling appearance what has
she done to herself
this is such a weird video too i saw it
first
it does look like she got ridiculous
plastic surgery and it makes her look
really bad
but there's a couple of things i wanted
to point out and i think this place like
cultural issues for one the obsession
with relevance on social media
clearly now
like this is like what did she post it
on tik tok yeah and everyone's sharing
it but i wonder if this is actually just
the front-facing camera making her look
yeah it looks like a fisheye lens of
some sort i don't think so because she's
posted other
photos and videos the bathtub thing on
her instagram and tiktok that make it
pretty clear that this is some pretty
heavy work being done and she like had
her butt done too
and it's one of those really obviously
fake situations where you don't even
know how they sit down on it gosh
uncomfortable so here look at this video
you can see it
it's just creepy
oh man it's so cringe it's so creepy
what is going on so here's here's why i
want to talk about this because it's
it's it's just it is kind of relaxing to
talk about the identity of of this pop
culture stuff but i also think
what people don't realize celebrities
get plastic surgery
and then they look really good and no
one says anything
but then when they age the weird scar
tissue doesn't age the same way a
regular face would so they start to look
really really weird as they get older
i used to take care of old ladies and
sometimes they'd get boob jobs
and this these things would stay where
they were implanted and the rest of the
lady would sag and i was like why did
you do this to yourself it was horrible
and you could just see them oh my gosh
it's horrible but anyway yeah i want to
advise people not to get plastic surgery
unless you have to
like for medical reconstruction or
something don't do it don't hurt why why
does anyone do it i really don't get it
i mean the only
situation i could see that's
semi-justifiable is if you're like a tv
personality and you get like a little
bit of botox to even out lines in the
forehead i mean something really minor
but why
vanity is a real thing and and
unfortunately when you have people on
social media for all of their lives i
think it's more difficult now than ever
to age gracefully and
people are really nasty about
appearances on the internet
my teeth are jagged like a jigsaw puzzle
i wear the same clothes every day i wear
a beanie all the time i got no hair or
whatever i'm not going to get surgery
i'm not going to get the you know i got
uh i got uh
crowns i think yeah that was because my
molar cracked i had a root canal when i
was little and then this one yeah
reconstructive surgery is fine i mean
you want to use plastic surgery for
reconstructive burn surgery stuff like
that that's what it's for i mean that's
that's a phenomenal advancement in human
medicine but don't rip up your face well
and did you guys hear about this story
with bella hadid the supermodel who got
a nose job when she was 14 years old
like her face wasn't even done growing
into itself yet and apparently her
parents signed off on this cosmetic
procedure and now of course she regrets
it she's like you know i had this really
interesting ancestral nose and i think i
would have grown into it and now i'm
forever living with the knowledge that i
modified myself in a way that i'm not
happy with when i was 14. they're gonna
get uh i was hearing stories about like
young girls wanting to get plastic
surgery to look like filters yeah and
that like older women are getting
plastic surgery to look like the filters
make them on instagram
yo there there is a there is a
malignancy
is it coming from the internet that's
making people like that's what i was
saying before about like social media
tick tock whatever making people do this
it's coming through the internet but
it's not from the unit it's coming from
people individuals are are either
inadvertently perpetuating a sick cycle
probably they want to look like cartoon
characters a lot of this like the whole
idea of for the furry thing like i think
i'm a
you know fuzzy animal no they don't
think they're animals i think they're
cartoons i think the most beautiful you
can be is who you really are
you don't need to mash up your face or
your body or any of that stuff it's so
it could be healthy too because it makes
you more beautiful to that yeah this is
the crazy thing to me too i've never
really understood why everybody wants to
be somebody else
not everybody well i i i mean that
figuratively i know because even i play
role-playing games i like to fantasize
about being a hero in a strange land you
know
sometimes it makes me a better performer
just thinking those things like living
on fantasy realities i mean like of
course we all we play games sometimes
there is escapism that i'm not talking
about that i'm saying how like people
are like they look in the mirror and
they're like i need to cut this up and
re-structure it i i want to be something
different it's like why i i don't
understand why you're not happy with
just being you i think that this
especially applies to women i don't know
if you agree with me on this 100 i find
it to be so much simpler to just be
yourself put a little bit of makeup on
paint the barn my dad used to say but i
think in madonna's case it's because
she's getting older and she knows it and
i think it's terrifying to her so she's
like really going out well especially in
like the world of pop stardom right you
almost have an age limit on how long
you're allowed to be relevant in the
industry
and there's a lot of pressure from music
executives to look a certain way uh i
mean like gone is the world of these
amazing like 70 singer-songwriters that
could look however but as long as they
delivered a good music product they
would be really successful
now there's really this pop star culture
where you kind of have to look and dress
a certain way in order to be popular in
the music industry and i think that's
really unfortunate and then there's the
question of just social media's
amplification of people's insecurities i
mean growing up like as a young teen
girl
i felt like we all had body image issues
and worried about our appearance
i can't imagine how much more difficult
that would have been
if i was on instagram all day looking at
these influencers who all look exactly
the same
yet none of them are real they all have
the plastic surgery or filters or all of
these other body modification tools to
their disposal
editing software photoshop things like
that
when you're fed that feedback loop
constantly
that's really hard for young women and i
i think
if you're a parent like you have to be
thinking about limiting your kids access
to social media and their phones as much
as possible no social media none i feel
i don't i don't want them to have a
phone nothing like you get a brick ipod
and that's it yeah and this is funny too
because i i several years ago i was like
i got my niece a cell phone so that she
could make you know learn apps and do
all this stuff and be tech savvy and
then i remember being like you know her
dad took it away saying i want her to
have this and i was like why would he do
that
now after a couple years i'm like oh
yeah yeah
yeah yeah take a look at this photo
right here oh these guys you guys oh no
i've seen this before look at these so
these are the two famous brothers
i think what are they called
twins did one of them die recently i
think they both yeah they both did why
would they want to look like that so
they were tv stars right so check this
out ready for this oh gosh
that's them when they were younger i
don't remember that before work they
they
right they still look weird starting to
look like everything else but like
that's the problem with work it makes
you look like everything else but i'm
wondering if vague and boring no no i'm
wondering if they got the work when they
were young and this is what happens when
you age with all that no that's more
work more work more work definitely yeah
they went overboard 100 did they think
they looked good yeah no i think it's
kind of like
they never did i think social or plastic
surgery is kind of addictive in the way
that tattoos are to some people yeah as
well that's how it is if you think you
look bad no amount of plastic surgery is
going to change that so these people do
it and then they still think they look
and then they do it and they still think
it's like comes from within this makes
me think a little bit of gender
reassignment because the problem is not
in your physical body it is 100 inside
your head and no amount of changing your
body
is going to fix what's going on in your
mind and this is what people who
detransition say they're like nobody
dealt with the problem that was you know
my thing i will say unless food
no amount of plastic surgery is going to
fix your mind but the food can fix your
body and your mind well look if you look
in the mirror and it's
i think plastic surgery cosmetic surgery
and
any kind of body modification surgery
any kind be it trans species like some
people do or transgender or whatever
i think you've got a disconnect between
your your perception your body or
whatever as you're mentioning that's the
issue like
the body dysmorphia yeah so my my my
issue here is
there's literally nothing you can do
unless we develop like nanotech cellular
cellular reprogramming or something and
then you go into like a stasis chamber
that
changes your body or something
we just do not have the technology to
actually give you something that
represents what you see in you know or
want or should we
i mean i mean i don't think well i mean
if if what if we literally develop
technology that you can like
actually
i don't know
physically change your body literally
legitimately in the future somehow then
i'd be like okay whatever i say okay
whatever to a lot look if these people
want to do this i got no problem with it
i'm just saying right now the technology
doesn't does not exist to make you look
the way you want to look right so right
now our best course of action is to
teach people that it's going to be hard
but you're going to have to change the
way that you think and you can use
cognitive behavioral therapy there are a
lot of different things that you can do
i don't know most people don't want to
go on to antidepressants i completely
understand that but right now we have
the power to change how you view the
world and even though i know it's hard
and every day might be a struggle people
who deal with addictions have this and
they overcome it and this is something
that they really get a grip on and every
single day is a struggle they still
manage to do it so i think if we can
change people's minds now we should make
that a higher priority so
let me ask this question though for uh
because you were saying they shouldn't
like people shouldn't modify their
bodies is that a fair assessment
uh i mean in cases that
where they have like a medical problem i
think that's different for for aesthetic
reasons no i don't think they should
like what if what if we get to the point
technologically
where you can actually take a
ten-year-old kid
and they walk inside a chamber and then
they actually completely change genders
like literally biologically one hundred
percent mm-hmm no you don't think they
should no absolutely not i mean and i'm
catholic so maybe this has like
something to do with it but i'm very
resistant to
altering
human nature in the way that we
experience the world i think that gets
to really dangerous places
what if they were
18
and they walked in and like like a genie
snap boom it was they were the opposite
sex i still think that's bad no yeah i'm
not about that at all it's an
interesting question because you know as
we're thinking about plastic surgeon all
that stuff i'm like is the issue
permanent body damage that these kids
are going to be many of them sterilized
or or you know is that the is that the
issue and then if there was a way that
the kid actually changed like to me i
don't support
gender transitions generally because i
don't think they address the underlying
issue which is the insecurity and the
body dysmorphia and then for kids it's
worse because it's life-changing and
they're not obviously of
of age to consent to that type of yo
it's going to be real crazy when we're
in the metaverse
you're gonna have a kid born in the
metaverse and they're gonna be like oh
hey mom i'm trans and then they like
click a button and their avatar just
changes but we're at the point when
we're at the point where your brain is
plugged in and their their digital
bodies are indistinguishable from base
reality then people are going to be
walking around like dragons and carrots
and there's going to be a rabbit
you're going to sit down in your office
and there's going to be a big rabbit and
he's going to be like hello i'm like
john you're both i just don't see any
way how that's not bad for like a truth
centric society right like we should
want people to try to seek truth this
will be crazy
if we get to the point where we
primarily exist in the metaverse
you could be born into a digital reality
where your brain's plugged in like the
matrix choose an avatar for yourself
that's say like a giant carrot and then
one day when the metaverse breaks down
and you get ejected from it you'll be
like oh what am i like i'm not a carrot
anymore
you'd freak out you know i actually took
some heat last week i know imagine that
on twitter again but i was talking about
this press release i got from this
company that is actually partnering with
the metaverse to create a narcos
experience in the metaverse so you
basically get to be a drug lord and like
run this cartel or whatever
like that but for me it's a different
experience when you feel like you're in
it right like that's westworld level
stuff
and i play video games like i'm
definitely not a person who says ban
video games because they lead to
violence or anything like that
but to me the metaverse and there's been
preliminary studies that have
talked about the effects of virtual
reality on the brain and apparently when
you're doing these things in the
metaverse or in virtual reality your
brain actually stores them or implants
them as if they were real memories
and so if you're going in and doing
violent stuff in the metaverse how does
that fundamentally alter someone's
perception of the world and what
negative effects could that have for
people's entire lives after that if you
think that you killed somebody or you
think that you were running drugs like i
don't see how that can lead anywhere
good for society
i think there's
we often talk about the negative things
about the metaverse but there's positive
things too you safety trainings you know
without real risk of harm for a lot of a
lot of issues training firefighters
trying police officers it's going to be
teaching people are going to go in there
with legalized psychedelics it's going
to be so crazy dude society is about to
split into it's going to about to
fractalize into a bunch of different
ways of being honest nuts dude different
laws different societies different
religions and relationships different
languages are going to start springing
up you know they're going to like in
north korea they'll take
thousands of citizens plug them into the
metaverse and just never tell them just
to like see what happens oh dude i've
been working on a script by the way i'll
tell you about it later but but think
about this reminding me so you have in
your country people who do physical
labor for producing food and resources
and machines and then you have
intellectual and abstract labor which is
like writing songs or developing code
software things like that
you could take all of your intellectual
property development people and put them
in the metaverse and just seal them off
and then they can do the same they can
they can do the work digitally with
their minds plugged into a computer and
then everyone else can just you know
till the fields and make food or
whatever yeah what will happen is their
mind will be working so fast but if
their body gets disturbed it'll slow
down their thought process and they'll
be like no we can't have that do not
disturb his body keep it sealed off so
his brain can work at peak capacity
imagine imagine right now
all of a sudden you're sitting you know
you're sitting wherever you're sitting
you're watching the show you feel this
pulling sensation in the back of your
head and then all of a sudden it feels
like you are actually being pulled out
of your body and then there's a flash of
light and you're standing in a field and
you're a duck
you'd freak out right yeah you'd be like
what is this like where are my hands why
am i a duck that's what it's gonna be
like for people who grow up in the
metaverse and choose to be a duck and
then when they get pulled out and
they're a human they're gonna be like i
have hands
their identity would be totally
fractured and separated from their
bodies you know i wanted to cap off this
um this plastic surgery conversation
because i was trying to bend my face
like i'd pull the bones open slowly over
time so like i'll spend an hour and just
hold it in place and i think it actually
slowly moves over time like clay
i can't tell if it's real or not well
that's why they tell women when you're
putting like moisturizer on your face
you're supposed to go like this instead
of like this yeah or like this the bones
are growing and moving you can slowly
over time move the like hold pull the
jaw outward if you want a bigger jaw and
stuff like that just takes a lot of time
yeah those ladies they put the rings on
their neck and they make their necks
right yeah
that's crazy
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there